in 1980 the great economist milton
friedman published free to choose
in it he extolled the virtues of free
market capitalism its ability to lift
hard-working families out of poverty
modernize entire economies and raise the
standard of living for everyone
the united states he and his wife
explained was among the finest examples
of what's possible when a government
simply takes its hand off the wheel
his utopia however was not the us but
rather somewhere halfway across the
globe hong kong
quote the modern exemplar of free
markets and limited government
so enamored was he with its faithful
application of capitalism that friedman
devoted many of his remaining years
delivering talks writing articles and
traveling the world telling its story
if you want to see how the free market
really works this is the place to come
it was such a textbook rags to riches
example in part thanks to its physical
transformation
this is victoria harbour around 1890 a
barren coastline the british government
was once indifferent to
here it is in the early 1960s
and finally this is hong kong in all its
vertical glory at the end of the 20th
century
today with 70 percent more skyscrapers
than new york it just exudes abundance
its gdp per capita already formidable on
its own becomes nothing short of
miraculous when compared to its once
colonial master
and while the us is more closely
associated with capitalism thanks to its
size in some ways it more closely
resembles finland sweden or denmark than
hong kong
according to the fraser institute and
heritage foundation there's no place on
earth with more private ownership lower
public expenditure simpler tax law or
less regulation
its leader is even called the chief
executive the very first of which was
quite fittingly don quinoa the
billionaire ceo of a shipping company
but what appears to be an almost
religious adherence to capitalism may
have been in fact more historical
happenstance
the great economist may have been wrong
all along
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch the bonus video
which accompanies this one for just 15
bucks a year
during the british empire colonial
bureaucrats were not sent directly from
london as you might expect but rather
hopped between crown colonies sir dennis
roberts for example began his career in
the army before being posted to
nyasaland a british protectorate in
africa followed by gibraltar and then as
the chief justice of hong kong
because of this by the time the sun
finally set on the empire with hong kong
as the last major holdout there had
developed a great difference in style
and philosophy between london and its
distant colonies
milton friedman called this an economic
experiment
britain and hong kong although both
british and name pursued two very
different economic systems one hands-on
and the other off
the reason in the free market narrative
was a man named sir john james
copperthwaite
copperthwaite was the financial
secretary during the 60s he believed
government intervention did more harm
than good and in any case was too hard
to predict
he accidentally became a kind of
capitalist hero after friedman met him
during a brief stopover
when asked about the local economy
copperthwaite replied that he honestly
didn't know the answer he was
philosophically opposed to keeping any
records as it might give the government
grounds to interfere
his successor gave this do-nothing
approach an academic sounding name
positive non-interventionism and the
rest is history
the true story however is quite
different
the first reason hong kong was so
financially prudent was that it had to
be britain expected that quote the local
revenue will be adequate to defray all
the expenses of the government of hong
kong
london even made the city pay for most
of the british garrison a giant
intimidating 30-story military base in
the middle of the city's financial
district
second with financial independence came
administrative independence
the british elite in hong kong had no
desire to cede control to london who
would surely attach conditions to
further funding
by spending so little the colony
remained self-sufficient and the rich
could enjoy their autonomy without
needing to beg the queen for help
they also worried generous social
welfare would attract too many migrants
from up north
and so between 1948 and 97 hong kong ran
a deficit for just 7 of 50 years
finally and most disturbingly
free-market ideology both distracted
from britain's failures and justified
its ethnic discrimination
contrary to what many believe hong kong
was never democratic bureaucrats were
appointed from 5 000 miles away and
never by popular vote
the supposed meritocracy of the
invisible hand of the free market was a
convenient scapegoat
it also provided the colonial government
with some source of legitimacy it was
supposed to be above politics composed
merely of neutral technicians allowing
citizens to prosper
in reality zoning laws elite schools and
favoritism all gave the one percent
british population an unfair advantage
as you can see capitalist policies were
driven less by ideology and more by
historical circumstances
and while its lack of natural resources
is often cited as further evidence of
its miraculous transformation this
argument relies on a very narrow
definition of natural resources
is strategically located geography like
that of hong kong or singapore not the
best and least corruptible of resources
but regardless of why it adopted the
policies that it did the hong kong of
today is either not an accurate example
of capitalism and practice or a striking
example of its perils
the list of monopolies is long
at its one and only container port the
world's eighth largest just two
companies hutchinson and modern together
control 21 of 24 births 87 percent
the privately owned jockey club is
granted a total monopoly on gambling
which in exchange sprays charity around
the city at a rate only guilt could
explain
the government carefully regulates both
the number of public buses and bus
companies resulting in only two major
players kmb and new world first bus
there are just two electric companies
china light and power and hong kong
electric which serve different areas
in a city of nearly eight million every
last pound of fresh beef comes from one
private company um fung hong who has a
complete monopoly on the license to
import cattle
likewise consumers have only one source
of gas but all this pales in comparison
to the hidden retail duopoly
just two conglomerates through a tangled
mess of subsidiaries own so many retail
stores that it would be nearly
impossible for someone living in hong
kong not to patronize at least one
on one side is jardine matheson which
owns dairy farm international which owns
every local mannings ikea welcome pizza
hut marketplace by jason's starbucks kfc
maxims and the city's 907 elevens
on the other side is ck hutchinson
holdings founded by hong kong's richest
man lee kashing
hutchinson
owns a.s watson group who owns three
fusion watsons park and shop taste and
fortress
watsons and mannings control nearly the
entire personal care market while park
and shop and welcome are the two largest
grocery stores
it should be no surprise then that
groceries are more expensive in hong
kong than tokyo singapore or the uk
and then there are the hidden taxes
while hong kong has no capital gains
sales withholding or value-added tax it
charges a very high stamp duty on homes
locals pay a standard 15 tax on homes
after their first non-permanent
residents pay 30 percent effectively
preventing any foreigner from ever
buying a home
but at least the government gets out of
the way letting the free market run its
course right
how else could it be ranked the most
economically free place on earth for
decades
to answer this question one need only
look to the food truck pilot scheme
in 2015 the hong kong government decided
food trucks at this point already
popular in cities around the world might
attract tourists
after nine months of study and one year
of preparation a pilot scheme was
launched only eight trucks would be
allowed for a city of 8 million
then there were the rules kitchens
needed to be at least 65 square feet
trucks required a 32 gallon water tank
and the sink had to be 1.5 feet long to
name just a few
to meet these requirements restaurant
owners had to invest in entirely new and
costly vehicles
changing any part of the menu required
approval from the government and no
tables chairs or tents were allowed
but they did make an app it conveniently
shows the location of each food truck oh
except they aren't allowed to move the
trucks must stay in the same location
and pay no less than 15 percent of gross
revenue on parking
ironically food trucks are perhaps the
best illustration of free market
capitalism the bad quickly fail while
the good remain chefs are free to
experiment with new dishes with low risk
and there are few barriers to entry
a perfect competitive environment that
benefits the consumer
so why so much regulation
what explains hong kong's laissez-faire
attitude when it comes to groceries
utilities and buses and yet it's
micromanaging of food trucks
in reality its bias is not in the
direction of free markets or
non-intervention in general but in
maintaining the status quo one that
benefits the largest corporations
hong kong appears to be a free market
paradise because it allows large
corporations free reign until only those
large corporations remain
but wherever there are small businesses
food trucks for example it suddenly
doesn't seem so ideologically strict
the only pattern to its behavior is
pro-business
one-third of employees work more than 48
hours a week making it the most
overworked city on earth
it has a low minimum wage and some ceos
were even allowed to bypass its kovid
travel quarantine one of the strictest
in the world
a more accurate word might be
corporatocracy rule by corporation
and there's a very good reason for this
in any country corporations are afforded
some of the same rights as we are the
ability to sign contracts and sue others
in court for example some countries even
describe corporations as legal people
but in hong kong corporations actually
vote
that's not hyperbole for political
influence no corporations legally cast
ballots
the hong kong election system is
deliberately complicated and difficult
to understand which is why i explain how
corporations vote in hong kong in a
separate unaffected by the youtube
algorithm video on nebula
almost every other polymatter video has
bonus or extended content available on
nebula as do many of your favorite
channels including entire nebula
exclusive originals like sam from
wendover's documentary on alaska tom
scott's game show or tier zoo's let's
play outside for just 15 bucks a year
not a month but a year you also get
access to curiosity stream home to great
documentaries like this one exploring
hong kong as a traveler or this one
about how the tallest building in the
world works
sign up with the link in the description
and watch the bonus video about hong
kong's election system over on nebula